we dug deep into Megan's origin story
and found out she not only made the cast
and crew uncomfortable on set all of
that stuff scared me but she cost over
12 million dollars to make her eyes take
more maintenance than anything else in
the film and there was a talented young
actor performing most of her stunts you
stay right where you are Katie there's
nothing to be afraid of the first thing
they did before trying to capture Megan
on screen was prove that she could
actually be made they worked with morat
FX Studios who built their first
real-life Megan doll which we should add
cost more than 12 million dollars to
produce the FX company built a real doll
but everyone thinks that it's CGI that
would have quadrupled the budget and
they didn't stop there do you like it
Katie they created more than half a
dozen versions of the doll they switched
between multiple versions of Megan Mall
filming as well as Amy Donald I love the
major in such a fun character to play in
there was animatronic Megan puppet Megan
posable and stunt Megan but we'll get
into that later for now let's talk about
how the ideas for the movie sprouted
from a casual conversation over drinks
between the producer Jason Bloom and the
writer Jason Wan the seed of Megan
really did come from that conversation
the idea was Annabelle meets the
Terminator what do you think did they
nail it according to the box office
definitely they're already set up for a
sequel in 2025. we'll definitely be
going into more detail on that in a bit
for now we have to talk about the dance
you know the moves this iconic dance had
social media and a choke hold before the
movie even came out gee brilliant Amy
Donald who plays Megan is actually a
dancer from New Zealand she represented
her country at the dance World Cup in
Portugal in 2019 and was the first ever
New Zealander to bring home medals the
director Gerard Johnson told her dance
teacher Kylie Norris that he wanted the
dance to be creepy and distracting those
were the only two qualifications before
he sent them off to create the viral
number Amy donald.co creating the dance
was a lot of fun but the Prosthetics she
wore yeah not so much so Amy Donald was
performing her own stunts while wearing
the Megan face neck and hand prosthetics
a lot of the time it would fog up so she
couldn't actually see so half the time
she was performing with extremely
limited Vision you'd think she'd be
scared to run blind in the middle of the
forest but she really went Full Throttle
with her stunts Amy really surprised her
director with her impressive ability to
COBRA rise where she oh so unnaturally
rises from the ground and then being
able to transition into a quad run he
just
I needed to to finish it and yeah so
yeah now one of the biggest things that
needed constant attention was Megan's
eyes they modeled her like a real human
which has never actually been done
before it was said that unlike a normal
puppet where the islands are far from
the surface of the eyeball Murat made it
just like a human beings the eyelid
slides right against the eyeball when it
opens and closes now this required a lot
of attention to detail between literally
every take they were administering tears
sometimes her eyes would even get stuck
while the cameras were rolling so they
had to reset quite a bit one of the
creepier moments was when Megan was
mid-sentence and one of her eyes got
stuck so they had to lubricate it people
were constantly running around the set
fixing up the different versions of
Megan leading us to our next topic it
was just such a fun concept that I
didn't really think about how
challenging it was going to be to bring
this thing to life the crew was pretty
much making things up as they went along
they didn't have time to complete the
research and development aspects of men
Megan until we were shooting so they
were thinking a lot on their toes it was
so often like oh we should should go
with this version of Megan or should we
go with this version of Megan and there
was confusion sometimes their director
would end up looking at a completely
different version of Megan than he
thought he'd be working with so let's go
with this version and see how it goes
and so yeah it was very complicated well
all that confusion
you shorted out in time for the seat
film was shot in news
actions in the US shooting there did
prove to be a major challenge though
they wanted it to look like it was shot
in the United States so they had to dig
deep to find the right places to shoot
the workplace was shot at Auckland
University of Technology though Gerard
Johnson was hesitant about it at first
because everyone in New Zealand does
know the university oh we can't go to
aut it's like it's how you take everyone
knows it so YouTube but it proved to be
the perfect set for the workplace and
most people from the US had never seen
it so he ended up giving in they even
used students at the University as free
background actors they never turned down
help on this set especially when it came
to Megan's mechanics come 2025 we'll see
just how Megan makes her way out of
gemma's alexa-like smart device here's
everything we know about that sequel so
far it's going to be called Megan 2.0
and it's set to release on January 17th
2025. akala Cooper who wrote the first
script will also be writing the second
one and Allison Williams and Viola
McGraw they're set to return as gem and
caddy I'm glad I did that that was I had
a good experience so much went on behind
the scenes to bring Megan to life from
those Vision impairing Prosthetics the
major stunt work involved the plethora
of creepy dolls created and the constant
eye maintenance we are completely
floored what was your favorite behind
the scenes Secret